I'd also like to thank the organizers
for inviting me to this very interesting
work
been trying to think more and more about
how the work I've done with climate
simulation and climate change really
connects up with the rest of the world
it's been very stimulating to me in
terms of thinking about how I should
really view my models and assess their
their capabilities and so this workshop
fits very neatly into that and I
appreciate the invitation what I want to
do my in this presentation what my main
goal is to sort of step back and try to
think about the future in terms of some
general principles that I'd like to draw
out of my experiences at looking at
climate change especially looking at the
water cycle and along those lines I also
think about what it is we we know but
also what we can't know I want to talk
about some of the uncertainties that
come up when we try to project the
future uncertainties in the water cycle
which then becomes very important for
thinking about how the numbers that we
pull out of our models the the volumes
and volumes of numbers really can
translate into what my colleagues call
actionable information usable numbers
that we can actually do something with
so that react we react properly to a
future climate change and not overreact
or under react but before I launch into
all that I want oh then I also intend to
draw some links to infectious diseases
basically echoing things that you heard
in much more detail this morning from
earlier speakers before I do that I did
graduate from Yale many years ago and I
want to give an acknowledgement to bury
Saltzman who was a professor here for
many years Barry is the person who
basically lured me into climate research
I was a physics and astronomy major here
but in many ways Barry was the person
who got me to the point of where I am
where I am today why I'm standing here
Barry was a terrific climate researcher
he won numerous accolades throughout his
career for the work he did including
receiving from the American
Meteorological Society the raspy award
which is the highest award that he gives
out for lifetime achievements back in
1998 but equally important Barry was a
thinks other people here already
recognized Barry was a very warm
wonderful human being and that was
probably also partly why I got Lou
word into doing climate research so many
thanks to Barry for why I'm here today
to lead into what I want to talk about
before I give you an outline i want to
just sort of say what I view the wat
global water cycle to be drawing from
this image from the US Geological Survey
as you can see it's a very other busy
figure because it traces all the
different ways that water flows through
our climate system the main pattern the
main cycle you might say is when water
evaporates from the oceans which cover
most of our planet goes into the
atmosphere condenses and then gets gets
transported around and gets condensed in
the atmosphere creating clouds with then
falling out is a liquid or solid
precipitation onto the land surface as
well as the ocean and then flowing
getting stored on the land in many
places but also flowing through the land
on the surface and under under the
surface and then basically getting back
to the ocean with all these other little
processes going on as well which can be
especially important in different
regions and in saying that I also want
to emphasize that even though i am going
to be focusing on some global scale
patterns and trying to draw out some
general principles that does not negate
the importance of looking at regional
details as we've seen in our previous
talks and hopefully complementing what
noah presented earlier as well also when
water condenses actually point out that
that puts energy into the atmosphere so
this whole water cycle is important not
only for the movement of water itself
where it accumulates or where it
disperses but it's also important for
providing energy for the circulation of
the atmosphere it is in fact the single
most important source of energy for
atmospheric circulation and that becomes
important to think about as well when we
start to think about climate change so
why is the global water cycle important
why is this global perspective important
and that leads into the the basic
outline and what I want to present today
I'll briefly talk about some prominent
water cycle and health links although I
think we've seen quite a bit about that
already this morning then I want to talk
about this important point that the
water cycle is expected to intensify in
various ways in the future
how do we simulate that possible future
climate I want to give you a little bit
of a primer on how we do global climate
simulations because it brings out some
of the important issues about what we
can know and what we can't know then
what are some of the features of
projected changes in water processes and
again thinking about how how well do we
know those changes and then finally some
few final thoughts on implications for
human health especially infectious
diseases so the water cycle has very
important roles in human health
vulnerabilities we've already seen quite
a bit this morning obviously it plays a
role in determining where and when
infectious diseases occur there are
other ways that the water cycle affects
our environment that one R and other
affects human health affects our
vulnerability to disease and also
affects the infrastructures that help
try to keep us healthy in spite of that
vulnerability so the lack of water is
Noah pointed out can be closely tied in
with heat waves especially the lack of
precipitation obviously thinking about
the opposite end of the spectrum of you
can get lots of water falling in places
through storms again those storms would
be powered in part by the condensation
of water into the atmosphere but I also
leading to flood accumulation of water
in places and again leading to the
breeding of disease vectors and again of
course the lack of water leads to
drought which causes some of its own
problems including infectious diseases
and it can in turn affect air and water
quality I'm listing all these in part
because we also need to think about
compound effects there was implications
of that and talks we had earlier today
but it's also important to keep in mind
when we start thinking about climate
change we need to be thinking about a
number of different variables I forget
who raised the question but there's a
question about how well do we assess
humidity simulations in these models and
we do to some extent but clearly most of
the discussion is usually talking about
temperature and precipitation changes
but there really are many many other
factors that come into play when you
start to think about all these different
sources of human vulnerability and human
health vulnerability it becomes
important to think about all those other
factors that come into play different
measures of the climate system and also
oh how they vary with time I want to
present this picture of recent water
stress this is from the IPCC fourth
assessment report so this is 2007 but
it's showing is this issue of water
stress it's computed by basically
estimating how much water is used for
various purposes in different parts of
the world and then dividing it by how
much water becomes replenished every
year what the annual water availability
is and you get this ratio that gives you
this color scale here and you can see
that there are numerous places around
the world and there they're not
necessarily confined just to developing
countries in fact often times it's more
developed regions of our areas that are
estimated to be experiencing water
stress in some places do not experience
water stress large because there is
little population there so there's
little demand for the water but this
water stress becomes an important factor
for thinking about how where how and
when we're vulnerable T vulnerable to
changes in the water cycle and i want to
emphasize you may be able to read these
little boxes here but i want to
emphasize a couple of them three of them
for a couple of different reasons 2007
report talked about multi-year drought
in the US and canada we're experiencing
substantial drought in the central part
of the country even now so this is
something that comes up repeatedly and
future projections are suggesting that
it's going to occur even more frequently
damage to repairing ecosystems due to
flood protection along the Elbe River
even though we try to put controls into
place it actually can lead to other
other problems and same thing with with
damage to aquatic ecosystems from
decreased streamflow increased salinity
of the murray-darling Basin this is
coming about large measure because of
increased agriculture in that Basin
which has changed the local water cycle
substantially and I'm pointing out these
last two factors here to emphasize the
point that changes in the water cycle
can have impacts that are not simply
poorly developed areas or areas with low
infrastructure they can have substantial
impact even in our well developed areas
and in fact a lot of our development and
many
may actually contribute to our
vulnerability to changes in the water
cycle okay how do we simulate possible
future climate well our primary tool are
these global climate models and I
putting this picture up to emphasize one
aspect of how we have uncertainty in our
projections to simulate the global
climate we need to break the plan it up
into little boxes or grid cells in which
we solve a couple set of equations and
multiple grid boxes in fact there's
generally speaking if we look at not
only the grid boxes that are populating
the surface here but all the little grid
cells that populate the atmosphere
columns and also the ocean columns we're
usually talking about over a million
grid cells in a typical global climate
model and several equations that are all
tightly linked together which makes for
a very complex numerical problem in fact
the more technical statement would be
it's a couple set of differential
equations based on fundamental
conservation laws if you understand that
that's fine but it's not really critical
the main point is that there are lots of
equations that we're supplying to solve
and but in doing that we cannot have
things in his fine details we always
might like Noah touched upon this
earlier and his talk talking about how
we need finer resolution in some places
and looking at this diagram here I'll
point out this shaded area here this is
outlining what the continent of
Australia looks like in this typical
grid representation so you can start to
see and get some feel for why there are
approximations involved in how we
represent climate when we do these
global climate simulations and that
becomes one of the first ways that we
start to encounter some degree of model
error or uncertainty in our projections
but only one of the ways there's also a
lot of complexity in the processes we
include in these models and this is just
a very sort of a cartoonish diagram of
what we see in these models and they've
gotten more and more complex as years
have gone by as people have tried to put
more and more processes and try to get
as close as possible to the overall
Earth's system so there are lots of
issues that are processes that
represented of course cloud
water condensing but also circulation in
the ocean and the atmosphere is implied
by these arrows and more recent times
people have started to include all sorts
of chemistry in the models not only the
ozone chemistry in the stratosphere but
also chemistry down where we live
looking at F lewins from different types
of industrial processes and also making
vegetation more and more like the real
world not only having it respond to the
whole annual cycle of of sunlight and
precipitation but also to actually grow
in decay and actually start to move
about within the climate models and in
addition to that becoming more and more
detailed there's no title for it here
but more and more detailed with how we
simulate how water moves through the
climate system so these have become more
and more complex that complexity
actually makes it even more difficult to
interpret the models in many respects
and understand what's going on but then
we're trying to understand the real
world which is equally if not more so
complex so we need these models so there
are different limits that start to occur
in our ability to understand what the
future actually holds these limits come
about because of the complexity of the
problem and our ability to represent it
well or not so well and then limits on
the knowledge of that complexity and the
computing power that we have to work
with one reason why we have the number
of grid boxes we have and not many many
more of course is the limitations on our
computers we could put in lots and lots
more grid boxes we could have very fine
scale resolution and we probably would
then be able to simulate the climate for
a year using about 10 years of our time
obviously that's not a real realistic
way to proceed so all of these lead to
different sources of uncertainty as I
already talked about the grid spacing is
one of them there are limits to just how
finally we can resolve different
processes there's also our important
knowledge shortcomings what should we be
including in these models what is
perhaps nice to include but not
necessary and even with what we include
how well do we understand the processes
we include a lot of things that are
included especially the the whole
business of
minus simulate water condensation cloud
formation precipitation is still in many
respects oding only rudimentary ly
understood there's lots more we need to
understand about how to represent these
processes well so these all become
uncertainties and there's also the whole
question of what people call structural
uncertainty which is what are the
unknown unknowns that we haven't even
thought about including is there
something out there lurking that's
actually very important and we just have
not learned enough about the climate
system to include it yet what are the
surprises that are awaiting us and then
going back to those complicated
equations the nonlinear mathematics
which in some ways are emulating what
goes on in the real world they bring
into play another kind of uncertainty
which is just the fact that in any
complex system there is a certain degree
of unpredictability that is always going
to be there that comes about from the
complex nature of all the interactions
that go on in that system there's a part
that's always going to be unpredictable
and we have to recognize that as well
and then of course finally humans all
I've talked about so far just basic
physical chemical biological processes
in many respects I'm always glad that
I'm just a physical climate scientist
because when I start to think about what
humans might do I just start to get
totally lost and that's and yet that's a
very important part of thinking about
the future because we have to understand
how humans are going to respond to
changing climate what types of controls
we may or may not put in place okay what
are the features of projected changes in
the water processes how well do we know
them this diagram here you saw something
like this earlier from NOAA this is
actually using more recent global
climate models the so-called see map
five models this is the change in global
surface temperature projected going back
over the historical period and then
projecting on well into the future the
reason why I'm showing you this here is
I don't want to always dwell on global
temperature because even though it's a
driver and gives a lot of information
about what to expect it of course is
global it's a global average but the
main reason why I'm showing you this is
this little box here that says future
scenario
this gets back at the human component of
all of this these things called RCP 2.6
4.56 point 0 8.5 those are all different
scenarios that people have put together
trying to estimate how humans might
respond to potential for climate change
and how they might do put in regulations
or no regulations to curb the growth of
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere and
in the oceans so there are different
degrees of control there in place this
RCP 2.6 assumes that humans are really
going to get together on a global scale
and enact global regulations and really
work very strenuously to put in
alternative sources of energy while not
constraining development overly to
arrive at a situation where the
emissions actually start to go down and
in fact even the greenhouse gas levels
in the atmosphere start to go down
giving you this leveling off of
temperature increase now I should point
out that the scale here is relative to
the year 2000 so it doesn't include the
increase also from the pre-industrial
period if you're thinking about that two
degree threshold that people have been
talking about as a sort of responsible
limit for how much warming we can allow
you have to add about point six degrees
to this scale here so really something
roundabout here would correspond to that
to degree limit this is the only
scenario that keeps us below that two
degree threshold these other scenarios
involve varying degrees of control or
lack of control going up to this RCP 8.5
which in some sense mimics what people
have talked about in the past is being a
business-as-usual scenario where
everybody just goes their own way
everybody just develops their own
resources their own energy supplies as
they see fit for their own own nation or
own region and there are essentially no
controls on the emissions in recent
years we've actually been following
something the globe has been following
something akin to this RCP 8.5 scenario
although I saw a figure just recently
that showed that the United States for
various reasons has actually had its
emissions start
to decrease partly because of controls
but partly because of economic reasons
and other factors so if we were to take
what's happened in recent years we might
say we're on this pathway but you can
also see that as you go through this
diagram that all these scenarios don't
really start to diverge substantially
until about mid century so to some
extent what that tells us is that we are
on a track to have some degree of
warming no matter what we do in a
reasonable way for the next 40 to 50
years or so and then after that what we
do and that includes issues that we
start to confront now start to have an
impact down the road in terms of what
pathway the earth follows as a whole
which means what we do now affects what
our children grandchildren and their
children will start to experience even
if we were able to stop emissions
completely right now through that type
of simulation that has not been done
with the set of models we would still
get some warming that occurs but that
would be obviously be so draconian and
unrealistic so these are all attempting
to be fairly realistic scenarios about
what humans might do but you can also
see that there's a spread and what the
response would be you also see there
shading about each of these curves that
shading represents the spread that you
get from all the different models and
these are the numbers of models that
simulated those different scenarios so
all those others uncertainties start to
come to play including that
unpredictability that's part of the
climate system this gives us some
measure of the uncertainty but usually
people understand that this is probably
an underestimate of the overall
uncertainty because there are other
factors lurking out there that we may
not recognize that as being important so
human factors become very important when
we think about the future especially
musi goat we go deep into this century
and we can also see some evidence in
this diagram as well of what it means to
have all those others uncertainties come
into play some of that uncertainty is
never going to go away including some of
the uncertainty about what humans are
going to do okay what do we see in terms
of some general principles that start to
emerge when we look at the globe as a
whole and in particular start to look at
regional patterns it's generally
recognized for
four regions I reasons I don't have time
to go into here that the global average
change in precipitation is going to
involve an increase in the global
precipitation of at a rate of about one
point one to three percent per degree
celsius increase what I've got plotted
here is the change in precipitation at
the end of the 21st century relative to
this baseline period that was
established for a reference point there
are important regional differences and
to understand those regional differences
I want to explain a little bit about
what's meant by this hatching and these
these dotted or stippled areas here the
stupid areas here are an estimate that
of places where we think we have a
fairly good confidence of the type of
change that will occur and maybe even
the magnitude of the change these are
places where the models generally agree
on the sign of the change show a fair
amount of agreement on the magnitude of
the change and that changes generally
much larger than that unpredictable part
of the climate system term that people
often that unpredictable part is
oftentimes called natural variability so
something that is a substantial change
relative to any natural fluctuations
that might occur and that leads to the
stippled areas here on these diagrams
and the hatched areas here are places
where there is much much less confidence
about what the change might be this can
come about because the change is
actually projected to be very small so
you might expect that relative to the
the noise of that variability there's
there's no confidence but it can also be
that the models just show very different
results and what they project that
change to be they may even disagree on
the sign of the change so those are
places where we do not have confidence
in the magnitude of the change the scale
down here is in percent showing you that
the degree of increase or decrease that
is projected to occur by am taking that
ensemble of models together to produce
these figures this is for the season
December January February 35 models
contribute to it June July and August
also 35 models contributed to it okay
some general principles that you can
extract from all of this generally
speaking we see in this generation of
models and also an earlier generation of
models that there are increases in
precipitation in the high latitudes
especially in the winter season this
occurs because the greatest amount of
warming is projected to occur especially
in the northern high latitudes warmer
air can have more moisture present so if
there's more moisture present then you
can have more falling out as
precipitation so in these high latitude
areas in both polar regions but
especially in the Arctic the key driver
is the fact that you have warming which
then can allow more precipitation to
occur it's sort of a contrast in the
process behavior in the low latitudes
generally speaking where you have more
precipitation you have less warming
because that greater precipitation
leaves more water on the ground there's
more water that can evaporate as you as
you would have recognized whenever you
step out of a swimming pool and water is
evaporating off your skin it cools you
off that cooling effect comes into play
on a large scale and our climate system
and in contrast where there's less
precipitation occurring that leads to
drying and as Noah talked about earlier
that can promote more warm you have less
of that evaporative cooling also of
course we have more precipitation you
tend to have more cloud cover that's
going to block the sunlight from heating
the surface so in the low latitudes
changes in the water cycle to a first
approximation or driving or at least
playing an important role in the
temperature changes rather than the
temperature changes driving the changes
and high latitudes a rough general
principle is a starting point is to
recognize that there's going to be a
tendency for areas that are already dry
to get drier areas that are already wet
to get wetter it's not a perfect
principle but it's a it's a good
starting point to think about for any
region in the world if you want to start
again getting down to the very detailed
regional behavior you of course do have
to think about local circulations and
local responses but to get a general
picture this is a useful principle to
keep in mind another principle to keep
in mind pertains to humidity levels in
the atmosphere which we've already heard
can be very important this shows the
change in atmospheric relative humidity
again same changes changes relative to
the same baseline
these are all using that RCP 8.5
scenario I should have pointed that out
on the previous slide as well so these
are showing in essence the maximum
changes that you might get or the most
confident changes again wintertime
northern weather in time December
January February June July and August
and then the annual average I could have
probably just put up just one of these
figures and giving you the same result
but I did it just to show you that it's
a very consistent behavior both for
mid-century here 2046 to 20 65 and also
at the end of the century but you see
especially over land very little
stippling lots of hatching over land
areas lots of stippling over the oceans
but that's because they have lots of
water available but the main point here
is that over land area is very little
stippling and fair amount of hatching
stippling showing up generally in some
dry areas the main points I want to make
here is that there's much uncertainty in
the change those especially over land
where you see lots of hatched areas and
also very little change the scale here
is only an increase or decrease of minus
ten to plus ten percentage points so a
general principle that emerges and we've
known about this from observations as
well and also from earlier generations
of models is that relative humidity
tends to stay fairly constant that leads
to a point that Noah made earlier that
humidity will tend to go up about 7%
absolute humidity or specific humidity
will tend to go up about seven percent
per degree Celsius warming so absolute
humidity can increase very rapidly that
means we can start to put more and more
moisture into the atmosphere and the
reason why we see lots of stippling over
the oceans is because the oceans are
persistent available source of water so
if the atmosphere can start to take up
more the oceans are going to readily
supply it but over land very little
change this is a very important
constraint on the behavior of the water
cycle soil moisture is one way of the
models do not always have those nice
hydrological models like we saw
discussed in Geoffrey's talk before mine
it'd be nice if they did but we can have
other proxies for one of them is that
the models do try to represent soil
moisture what you see here is that the
scale here is drying
the red darker shades wedding and the
bluer shades what you see is again large
areas of hatching over land except for
areas where there's drying the soil
moisture becomes an indicator of where
water might or might not be accumulating
on the land surface which obviously has
disease implications areas of
significant drying are areas where there
are there's reduced precipitation and
those are the only areas that really
show up with lots of stippling so fair
amount of confidence that there's air
there's going to be drying in many parts
of the planet no areas of significant
increase in soil moisture even in the
far north where there was substantial
and significant increases in
precipitation the soil moisture itself
is not changing very much that's
occurring in part because not only does
precipitation increase but as it gets
warmer you have stronger evaporation and
stronger transpiration from plants so a
lot of that moisture just goes right
back into the atmosphere or it goes into
runoff runoff is the models way of
representing what flows and rivers even
though a lot of these models do not have
rivers themselves again changes from the
same baseline period to the end of the
century this is the annual average 28
models so now you see significant
changes in the runoff and high latitude
so a lot of that water is going into the
rivers possibly accumulating in places
possibly increasing flooding possibly
leading to new water bodies that could
be breeding grounds for various types of
mosquitoes and other other insects
otherwise a fair amount of hatching and
clearly some significant decrease in
runoff where you have drawing so areas
of significant drying or areas of where
there's reduced precipitation reduced
flow of water into rivers and again note
the degree of confidence we have and
going from region to region here some
places we're more confident about some
of these changes than others and as
Jeffrey showed and his talk is very
important to think about all these
different aspects of the water cycle
that i showed you not simply just
precipitation when you want to start
thinking about the disease implications
okay finally just some implications of
all this for human health which really
again is echoing a
lot of what we heard earlier today
focusing just here on Africa this is
from the IPCC fourth assessment report
as well places where there's high
mortality risk due to water factors and
there are water factors involving
droughts increasing in some places water
factors involving what they say hydro
only meaning changes in precipitation
and the whole more intensification of
the water cycle but equally important
these compound factors of where you can
have droughts and changes as well as
hydrological changes basically a lot of
increase in drought but also increases
in precipitation but seems somewhat
contradictory sometimes as you can have
in any given location you can have an
increase in drought because
precipitation may occur less and less
frequently but at the same time when
precipitation does occur it may occur
much more in enlarge downbursts that can
cause flooding and that can happen
simply because you have more water vapor
present in the atmosphere and that
warmer warmer climate so you can have
increased flooding and increase drought
both going on in the same place which
then has lots of implications for how we
think about infectious diseases going
into the future and that can lead to
complex and serial disasters we already
saw actually Thank You Jeffery and your
talk talking about how it's important to
have periods of dryness followed by
periods of wedding to promote certain
disease vectors well that can occur in
very another complex ways or in serial
ways of different events following each
other and that can amplify the
vulnerability to all sorts of human
health problems again drawing from the
IPCC fourth assessment report changes
that where the places where they're
expected to be high risks zones for
malaria changes you actually saw this
figure earlier and also changes due to
epidemic meningitis with malaria again
other people have talked about this a
much better detail than myself even
though there's endemic malaria in this
white area in the middle it's when it
starts to spread to other locations that
you encounter vulnerable populations who
maybe aren't
quite so hardened against it or haven't
taken all the appropriate measures to
protect against it the interesting thing
about meningitis showing up here is it's
due to reduction in the intensity of the
water cycle increased dryness low
humidity and dusty conditions so again
echoing re-emphasizing that point that
we have problems when we have too much
water but also problems when water
amounts go down they can lead to
development of meningitis so finally and
I'm also showing this last figure here
this is also from the IPCC fourth
assessment report this was their
estimate of degrees of confidence in
terms of how climate change can affect
human health and what I'm putting this
up here for is to bring out the fact
that most of these are related to issues
revolving water the contraction and
expansion of malaria zones are related
of course to temperature but also to
issues of humidity precipitation and
drought possibly there could be places
where malaria contracts so beneficial
effects of climate change but they drew
a slightly larger arrow indicating that
probably overall it's going to be a
negative consequence changes increased
malnutrition increases the number of
people suffering diseases and deaths and
injuries from extreme weather events
probably tied into changes in droughts
and floods as well as pests that can
carry diseases as a sidenote it was
interesting that noah mentioned corn
before because having lived in the
midwest for 20 years now I've ery much
appreciate what corn means and also how
corn pathogens get transmitted one side
effect of global warming is that pests
that used to get killed off in the
winter time and could over winter over
only very far south of Iowa and
therefore need it all summer before they
could even get up to Iowa now can winter
over much closer to Iowa so we're seeing
diseases for corn that are starting to
spread into our region much more readily
okay increased frequency of cardio
respiratory diseases again meningitis
drought can promote dusty air so you may
get flooding in a region but we also get
droughts promoting dusty air
and any cardio respiratory disease can
be effective that way changes in the
range of infectious disease defectors
we've already seen lots of information
about this obviously it's related to
temperature but also changes in the
water cycle and finally burden of
diarrheal diseases are related to water
quality influenced by stagnation and
again places where you have increased
heavy downpours you're more likely to
have flooding accumulation of water that
can lead to diseases so to summarize
despite the various uncertainties that I
talked about there are some things that
we have confidence about looking towards
the future there's generally going to be
a tendency for wet areas to get wetter
drier areas to get drier again don't
view this as being a hard and fast
principle it depends on specific
locations and how the circulation
changes but if you want to start
thinking globally or in broad scale
about infectious diseases this is a
starting point for thinking about how
things will change and as I pointed out
some places may experience both changes
more intense rain events and more
drought water changes of all kinds as
I've also pointed out and as our
previous talks that pointed out have
important implications for disease
transmission and as I also emphasized no
one is immune from the impacts of water
cycle changes and therefore these water
cycle changes can affect all of us no
matter where we are thank you for your
time